-Good evening.
I'm Seth Meyers,
and this is "Late Night."
I hope you're all
doing well tonight.
And now I would like to
get to the news.
The CDC announced last wee
that fully vaccinated American
no longer need to wear masks
in most indoor
or outdoor settings.
"Oh, my God, finally!",
said unvaccinated Americans.
After the CDC
announced it on Thursday
that vaccinated people no longer
need to wear face masks indoors,
House Speaker Nancy Pelosi
said that masks
will still be required
in the chamber.
And when Marjorie Taylor Green
heard that,
she became so unhinged
that nobody noticed
any change in
her demeanor whatsoever.
According to
"The New York Times,"
President Biden
does not make quick decision
and often asks for
detailed briefings and debates
from staffers
before making up his mind,
which is honestly refreshing
considering the last guy
didn't always get
the wrapper off the burger
According to a new poll,
only 52% of Americans
say they trust the CDC.
Reached for comment,
the CDC said, "Ask again later."
According to a new report in
"The New York Times,"
First Lady Dr. Jill Biden
is a wine connoisseur.
Dr. Biden first
became interested in wine
the 38th time
she heard about Scranton.
"I'm just going to
top this off."
According to a new survey,
72% of Americans
think they could beat a ra
in a fight.
9% think they could beat
a crocodile.
And 6% think they could beat
a grizzly bear.
This news first reported
by the kid
you're trying to get to bed.
"I don't know.
Uh, I guess rat, yes.
Crocodile, maybe."
Researchers in Japan
recently found that mammal
that have been deprived
of air can be saved
by receiving oxygen
through their anuses.
While researchers deprived
of oxygen
come up with
some pretty wild stuff.
A 111-year-old man in Australia,
who is believed to be
the country's oldest-ever man,
said in a recent interview
that the secret to living a long
life is eating chicken brains.
Oh, I didn't even know you could
get Hot Pockets in Australia
And, finally,
today was National Walnut Day.
Celebrate by ruining
some chocolate-chip cookies.
That was the monologue,
everybody.